en france 600 à 700 femmes choisissent
chaque année d'accoucher dans le secret
de leur admission et de leur identité
isabelle jeanne andré bonsoir messieurs
nous vous recevons ce soir parce que
vous publiez elle est rose du mensonge
secret d'une né sous x un récit
autobiographique autour de la quête de
ses racines
c'est un témoignage très fort poignant
autour de votre histoire vous y relater
les différentes étapes de votre vie on y
voit aussi se dessiner on en parlera
tout à l'heure les étapes de
l'engagement dans un combat parce que
vous vous êtes engagés au fur et à
mesure de ses différentes années vous
avez voulu avec ce livre faire savoir
que la naissance sous x véritablement
c'est une souffrance et c'est une
aberration aussi oui les deux voeux les
deux c'est une souffrance est une
aberration c'est une souffrance parce
que il est inconcevable de ne pas savoir
d'où on vient
ni de qui en est née reconnaître un
enfant c'est pas forcément accepté d'en
prendre la charge
c'est juste le reconnaître comme celui
qu'on a mis au monde et les choses
peuvent s'arrêter là faut savoir que la
france est le ce quasiment le seul pays
qui à l'accouchement sous x
les autres pays d'europe ne l'ont pas
sauf une exception avec les pays bas et
une petite aussi avec l'italie mais le
c'est une bombe août on essaie vraiment
dit ça remonte à la révolution française
c'est justement ça dans l'abandon se
pressent à évoluer au fur et à mesure
des a évolué d'ailleurs les lois qui
régissent encore l'accouchement sous x
sont celles de du régime de vichy qui
avait été mis en place pour protéger les
femmes qui avaient des enfants
avec l'ennemi voilà on est toujours avec
ce dinosaure qui n'a plus de sens et
avec les progrès que fait la psychologie
et la pédopsychiatrie aussi on se rend
compte que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui ne devrait plus être parce que ça
empêche l'enfant véritablement de se
construire vous le dit c'est pas
nécessairement pour que le parents
s'occupent de l'enfermer au moins que
l'enfant par la suite quand il devient
plus grands puissent connaître ses
racines savoir d'où il vient de quelle
est sa ligne et c'est ça pour faire
ensuite il ya deux choses
il ya là la première chose qu'un 15 nés
sous x 10 quand on lui parle quand on
lui pose la question pourquoi pourquoi
chercher il va dire qu'il a besoin d'une
histoire et c'est vrai qu'on a besoin
d'une histoire pour comprendre pourquoi
on est là et pour que ça ait un sens
maintenant il ya une deuxième chose qui
est existante dont on parle pas parce
que c'est pas envisageable tellement
c'est que l'accouchement sous x ça c'est
une histoire qui débute avec un abandon
un abandon c'est un nourrisson qui va se
retrouver tout seul et qui à ce moment
là n'a pas de
verbe pour pouvoir mettre des mots sur
sa souffrance et c'est un arrachement
littéralement un arrachement est en fait
il ya un besoin de rattraper son
histoire mais là pas il n'y a pas
d'histoire qui justifie dans l'absolu un
abandon ou qui le justifient pas chaque
femme peut avoir un jour la nécessité
d'abandonner un enfant et en même temps
pour l'enfant ça reste toujours pas il
peut comprendre mais ça s'entend mal
c'est quelque chose qui s'intègre mal
quand même d'avoir été abandonnés voilà
mais cet arrangement la de l'enfant
c'est quelque chose qu'on enfin du
nourrisson c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'on traîne toute sa vie et sur
laquelle on peut pas travailler parce
que c'est juste des sentiments et c'est
pas quelque chose qui aurait pu être
verbalisé donc qu'ils ont parlé vous
dites justement tout même dans cet
ouvrage vous parler de ce que vous avez
été adopté à l'âge de neuf mois
oui et de ses neuf premiers mois vous
gardé des souvenirs oui vous en parlez
vous les écrivais oui vous vous souvenez
de ces moments oui c'est surprenant
parce que oui j'ai rêvé général on ne se
souvient pas de ces premiers noms se
sont pas des souvenirs d'image réel ou
de ce sont les souvenirs de sentiments
c'est quelque chose qui est pas voilà
qui est pas verbalisés on peut le
décrire
mais on est incapable de donner des
détails précis par contre on sait
pertinemment se souvient pertinemment de
ce qu'on a ressenti et c'est c'est
vraiment grave et dans un coin du
cerveau qui n'a jamais été nettoyée
puisque on garde en mémoire tous tout ce
qu'on a ressenti avant d'apprendre le
langage mais ensuite il faut essayer de
se construire à travers ses différentes
étapes de sa vie en gardant cet héritage
là justement ces neuf premiers mois en
ce qui vous concerne avant d'être adopté
il a fallu plus de 40 ans 46 ans avant
que vous
nier envie en tout cas le déclic pour
publier écrire cet ouvrage vous me
disiez tout à l'heure que ça a été très
rapide ensuite pour l'écrire mais il a
fallu tout de même un déclic
à quel moment vous vous ai dit il faut
que ça il faut que ça sorte que ce soit
par écrit et voilà j'ai eu envie c'est
au départ un livre que j'ai eu envie
d'écrire pour mes enfants je veux ne
compte je n'avais même pas l'idée d'en
faire un livre avec une couverture et je
voulais laisser une trace écrite à mes
enfants je trouve que on a besoin de se
référer à une histoire j'avais perdu ma
mère adoptive
il ya quelques années et je me suis
rendu compte plusieurs fois je me suis
dit rien il ya des tas de choses
pourraient plus lui demander
on a des fois des questionnements dans
les oublie on se disait on remet à plus
tard on posera la question demain et
puis un jour c'est trop tard et moi j'ai
eu envie du coup de laisser une trace à
mes enfants avec une histoire qui soit
vraiment construite chronologiquement et
aussi c'est une façon de m'excuser parce
que quand on est en recherche
c'est quelque chose de viscéral et en
tant que maman on essaye d'être là et on
n'est pas complètement là pour son
entourage non plus il ya une partie qui
est jamais parfaitement dans ses
chaussures parce que vous avez été en
recherche pendant une très grande partie
de votre vie alors pas dès les premières
années mais c'est vers quel âge on peu
près vers l'adolescence où vous avez
commencé à vous poser un peu plus de
questions par rapport à des éléments
vous avez eu qui sont fabriqués selon
elle m'en suis toujours posé j'ai eu en
fait c'est un peu comme un deuil on dit
qu'il ya différentes étapes dans un
deuil mais je crois que depuis
l'annnonce de l'abandon enfin la prise
de conscience de ce que c'est qu'un
abandon juge jusque là au moment où on
se dit qu'on va rechercher et même au
delà
on doit aussi franchir tout un tas
d'étape et il ya des étapes qui passe
aussi par la colère il ya des les étapes
qui passe par le déni j'ai eu toute une
période de ma vie adolescente où je
voulais pas savoir et je voulais surtout
pas chercher et je me disais que 2 500
l'exemple à 18 ans et à 18 ans qu'on a
le droit d'avoir accès à un les éléments
en tout cas du dossier de votre
naissance mais ce n'est pas à 18 ans
pour autant que vous êtes allé les
chercher ces éléments non et ça c'est le
âmes et pourtant oui parce qu'en fait on
a on aménage parle pour nous parce que
comme je suis en contact avec beaucoup
de gens dans mon cas je sais c'est
quelque chose que je peux constater
comme général mais on a toujours cette
crainte d'être ingrat vis-à-vis des
parents adoptants adoptifs
si on recherche des origines et de les
mettre en concurrence alors qu'il ya pas
de concurrence il y en a pas chaque
parent a fait sa part et en a qui ont
mis au monde
il y en a qui ont élevé une personne
peut prendre la part de l'autre ils sont
vraiment complémentaires mais on a
toujours cette peur de se dire s'ils
savent que je recherche ils vont se dire
qu'il ne me suffisent pas et qu'on ait
trahi quelque part qu'on est un con et
traille est vous l'avez dit vous êtes en
contact avec d'autres nés sous x parce
que je le disais en introduction vous
vous êtes engagé ensuite pour des
associations d aide à la recherche vous
aider aussi les autres huit enfants dans
la même situation que vous à retrouver
leurs parents
c'était aussi nécessaire pour vous de
vous engager de cette manière là d'avoir
un combat véritablement vous avez
manifesté aussi pour ça pour la wii que
le
v par exemple de ce secret de cette
naissance mais je trouve qu'on est on
n'est pas entendus il faut d'abord il ya
quelque chose qui est la solidarité
entre nous parce qu'on n'a pas besoin de
se parler pour savoir ce qu'on ressent
et en plus c'est quelque chose qu'on dit
pas il ya quand même un gros tabou
autour de l'adoption surtout des gens de
ma génération et des précédentes on ne
parlait pas facilement de l'adoption les
parents ne le disait pas et non par les
pales entourage non plus donc on a
quelque chose entre nous comme ça qui
nous rend très solidaire on a beaucoup
de mal à se faire entendre parce qu'en
face de nous on a le lobbying des
parents adoptifs
on a les défenseurs des droits de la
femme qui savent pas le mal qu'ils font
aux femmes parce que je parle des né
sous x men aux associations elles sont
pleines de maman naissance qui sont qui
ne se remet pas de cet abandon et qui
trouvent que d'avoir coupé les liens
avec les avoir empêchés de donner leur
identité
avec ce côté irréversible c'est une
douleur dont elles peuvent elles peuvent
pas faire grand chose pour pour lieux
pour s'enquérir étant donné que
rechercher leurs enfants
ça leur est aussi difficile pour elle
que nous retrouver nos parents en 2002
il ya eu une évolution un petit peu du
côté de la loi en tout cas des
politiques qui s'était saisi du problème
ségolène royal qui avait poussé à la
création du conseil national pour
l'accès aux origines personnelles
ça avait servi à quelque chose
aujourd'hui onze ans après il n'y a pas
beaucoup cru dans cet organisme
dans les faits il a finalement très peu
de pouvoirs pour faire des recherches et
il ya une très mauvaise gestion et du
contact avec les enfants qui ont été
abandonnés et avec les mamans naissance
aussi bien qu'on se sont elles qui font
les démarches pour retrouver leurs
enfants que quand on droit à les
contacter et enfin le look now up doit
les contacter pour parce qu'un enfant
les recherches
voilà donc il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de travail à faire avec cet
organisme il
il ya eu un rapport aussi je reste dans
l'aspect purement de la loi un rapport
parlementaire remis en début 2011 qui
proposait de faire évoluer la loi en
transformant l'accouchement sous x en
accouchement dans la discrétion
c'est l'idéal c'est ce qui se passe par
exemple en belgique ça préserverait
l'identité jusqu'au 18 ans de l'enfant
et à 18 ans l'enfant s'ils le souhaitent
pourraient connaître l'identité dire des
choses qui font comprendre parce que
sinon comprends pas ce que c'est que
l'accouchement sous x c'est que on
prétend que c'est fait pour protéger les
mères en fait les maires n'ont besoin de
protéger leur identité que vis-à-vis de
la société
mais elles ne comprennent pas parce qu
on leur explique pas et que même quand
on leur explique elle l'intègre pas que
l'accouchement sous x rond les liens
complètement et que c'est derrière
complètement irréversible elles n'ont
pas envie de cacher leurs noms de leurs
enfin vis-à-vis de leurs enfants elles
ont envie de le cacher vis-à-vis de la
société qui pourrait les juges et qui
pourraient voilà mais vis-à-vis de
l'enfant non et en belgique
il va en voit des enfants qui sont donc
nés mais pas sous x sous accouchement
protégé et qui sont qu'attendent
sereinement la majorité qui ont tout le
temps de tisser des liens parfait avec
les parents adoptifs imparfait dans le
sens sans angoisse sans justement
questionnement qu'est ce qu'ils vont
dire si jamais je recherche puisqu'il
sait tout le monde sait que de toute
façon l'enfant pour voilà personne ne
compte sur l'anonymat pour empêcher quoi
que ce soit il ya beaucoup de
discussions actuellement retour de
mariage pour tous de ce mariage
homosexuel et puis ensuite il y aura
l'assemblée une autre discussion autour
d'une évolution tourner la loi des
familles avec l introduction sans doute
de
la procréation médicalement assistée de
la gpa aussi la gestation par autrui
vous en pensez quoi j'ai pris un pma gpa
pma ils ont exactement ils vont se
retrouver ce sont des gens qui vont être
amputées de 50% de leur origine c'est
déjà dramatique je suis pire encore pour
la gpa on se retrouve avec le même
problème que pour les né sous x à savoir
qu'il ya une question de l'arrachement
de l'enfant qui n'est et qui se retrouve
subitement complètement coupée de celle
avec qui il a été relié pendant neuf
mois et c'est encore pire
donc je suis pas dans l'absolu je suis
persuadé qu'un enfant peut parfaitement
grandir heureux au milieu d'un couple
homosexuel je n'ai aucun doute là-dessus
la seule chose qui m'angoisse c'est
l'augmentation du nombre de candidats à
l'adoption
parce qu'on sait en france mais on n'en
parle pas qui a quand même énormément
d'incitation à l'abandon pour la bonne
raison que ça coûte beaucoup moins cher
pour une pour la société et pour l'état
de faire adopter un enfant que d'avoir à
aider la mère et l'enfant avec tout un
tas de
dell sociales diverses et variées dont
il ya l'incitation des les cliniques dé
les maternités quand une femme est en
situation difficile on lui propose
immédiatement l'abandon et pas l'abandon
tout seul parce que pourquoi pas ça
n'empêche pas l'abandon sous x
obligatoire que vous parlez de
l'administration justement des choses
qu'on ne dit pas forcément lorsque vous
avez voulu accéder à votre dossier vous
avez eu le sentiment est ça aussi vous
l'écrivez qu'on vous cacher des choses
oui on savait le sentiment encore
aujourd'hui quand j'en ai la preuve j'en
ai la preuve je me suis rendu trois fois
l'aide sociale à l'enfance pour voir mon
dossier trois fois la loi le stipule
qu'on a le droit à l'intégralité du
dossier
alors il s'amuse beaucoup à mettre du
blanco sur les des noms quand il ya la
notion secret mais normalement tous les
documents doivent y être et moi les
trois fois où je suis allé à la dass les
trois fois mon dossier était différent
aujourd'hui
votre combat vous en ai tout ce combat
ont continué les recherches
je continue les recherches je continue
et je crois que je pourrais pas je
pourrai pas arrêté est-ce que vous avez
changé la proche en tout cas de ces
recherches vous vous sentez peut-être
aussi plus apaisée d'avoir en tout cas
mis sa part écrit de pouvoir le
transmettre à d'autres c'est un
témoignage aussi pour vos enfants petits
enfants etc oui oui oui nous mais je
suis apaisé par le livre mais il
n'empêche que j'ai toujours cette place
vacante énorme et monumental qui reste à
combler voilà pas seulement parce que
j'ai besoin de savoir qui je suis mais
moi j'ai foncièrement besoin de savoir
qui est ma mère merci beaucoup d'être
venu sur son plateau pour témoigner je
rappelle cet ouvrage les roses du
mensonge que vous éditez d'ailleurs pour
se le procurer il ya un site internet un
facebook aussi où on peut avoir toutes
les informations
et puis vous pourrez bien évidemment
n'hésitez pas à contacter la rédaction
et nous vous donnons toutes les
informations pour vous procurer cet
ouvrage en savoir plus sur votre
parcours et toutes les étapes de votre
vie depuis la naissance et tous ces
témoignages très précis que vous relatez
à travers ses différentes pages merci
beaucoup
nous allons à présent parler d'un tout
autre sujet avant de débuter la page
culture puisque nous allons parler
économie et l'implantation du siège de
mercedes à saint quentin en yvelines